today is wednesday july 8th and covid is
still happening in los angeles
the medical icu is full surgical icu is
full
there's not a single icu bed open in the
hospital
[Music]
it is friday today is saturday
just another really hard day holy crap
he comes back to life heart starts
beating there's a real blood pressure
i'm like
an icu nurse can only take care of one
or two patients we are busy here
we are drowning
you know with california reopening and
los angeles sort of getting back to
regular life but the outbreak
you know being quite far from under
control
we've sort of gone back to regular modes
of functioning at the hospital
plus covid i just sort of never really
imagined that it would happen in that
way
we're doing tons and tons of trauma july
is a very busy month for traumas for
example
i was on call yesterday and had a couple
of gunshot patients come in who needed
emergency surgery
who happen to have covet so community
spread is very
common and very prevalent there are tons
of asymptomatic people coming to the
hospital for other problems who
happen to have covets that's putting a
strain on our system because
we don't have the specific isolation
beds that we might need for such a
patient
i've been sort of surprised by that
that's just not what i pictured
the er occasionally here will go on
diversion except for the most critical
of trauma cases
and then just the other night we
finished two cases in the middle of
night one was a stab wound to the
abdomen one was a
gunshot wound through the arm and
through the belly and the
gunshot wound guy had covid and the
other guy uh did not but neither had an
icu bed available so they had to just
sort of park for the in the or for like
six hours while they waited for a spot
so
that's sort of what's going on these
days um still got my mask
everybody's hanging in there
[Music]
good morning it's thursday july 9th it
is 5 50 in the morning and i'm coming in
to work
covered numbers going up and if you look
at the curve in los angeles we had
just like in the rest of the united
states a big spike in april
which began to come down a little bit in
may which sort of flattened but never
really went away
and now numbers are going back up so the
curve
in los angeles looks very similar to the
curve in the rest of the united states
with a big spike
a little bit of flattening and then up
it is still thursday july 9th
it is now 7 30 p.m i am here
on my little porch in my little rocking
camping chair
and meanwhile my phone is blowing up
trying to get me to move people out of
the icu because the ed
is so full of icu patients they have
nowhere to go
so they are trying to push current icu
patients out
out as fast as possible you know when
the system stretches everybody suffers
not just covet players
i have a bunch of covet patients who are
in the covid
unit but have primarily trauma and
surgical problems
and i was asked to move them out of the
icu and i think it's too early because
they still have ongoing issues and we're
sort of
grasping at straws as to which patients
would be safest to move
[Music]
good morning it is friday
july 10th i got a text last night
letting me know that our hospital has
reached
capacity for the number of patients who
required dialysis
so we have no more dialysis machines
as you guys probably have heard by now
um
covet is not a respiratory illness what
it actually
is is a vascular illness the virus
attacks the tiniest little blood vessels
in the body
you know there happens to be some of
those in the lungs but there also
happens to be a lot of those in the
kidneys so
many patients when they get very
critically ill go into kidney failure
it's going to be a problem
for our trauma patients we've been
advised to transfer
early if we have patients who we think
are going to need dialysis which is
crazy like where are we supposed to send
them that you know
um so we'll see happy friday
one sort of interesting thing that has
happened over the last couple weeks
is patients who initially
tested negative for kofit on the way in
the door of the trauma bay
uh have become positive
later in their hospital stay as they're
literally rolling in the door
somebody jabs a q-tip in their nose and
sends that off to the lab we test every
single patient who gets admitted to the
hospital
before they go out to rehab or something
the rehab place will ask for another
confirmatory negative test and we'll
send it and it'll be positive
some of those folks are asymptomatic but
i have another patient who
developed fevers a cough and a funny
look at chest x-ray
we actually luckily are not
bursting at the seams anymore in the icu
we do have beds available but we are
still on diversion meaning ambulances
are still not bringing us patients
except for trauma because we actually
don't have enough respiratory therapists
in addition to needing physical space
for patients we need enough staff
an icu nurse can only take care of one
or two patients
a respiratory therapist who's the person
who runs the ventilators
they can only have i think it's five or
six here
so our hospital is not full but we still
are not taking
new patients for that reason
hey everyone it is monday july 13th
it's 8 p.m um just got home and showered
um just another really hard day
we just had this young girl in her 30s
just
die of a massive overwhelming soft
tissue infection of the arm
um there was nothing we could do and it
went from
zero to 90 in like just a couple hours
she was
impacted by the covid um outbreak
because
her family couldn't really be with her
in her last moments
um and that's unfair and
so much of this is unfair one
aspect that people probably have heard
about in the press
is the disproportionate effect that the
covid pandemic is having on patients of
color
you know in los angeles county it's
something like a third of the population
is
hispanic but they represent 70
of all hospitalized patients there's a
lot of reasons and
some of them include the fact that most
of those people
are working on front-line jobs where
they
can't work from home and they are the
people that are keeping the economy
going
working in deliveries working in the
restaurants working in the service
industry
these folks are not able to self-isolate
and protect themselves
in los angeles county two percent of all
inpatient admissions for covet have been
white people which is obviously vastly
underrepresented of how many white
people there are in los angeles county
so
um that's unfair right and
decisions and policies that open the
economy
too early are racist policies uh because
they will have a
disproportionate effect on the health
and life
of people of color our government has
just kind of wished this virus away and
it's still here and
we're opening and actually today los
angeles and california governor newsom
said that we're taking a step back and
opening so
i'm proud of that policy people are at
their wits end at the hospital
so that's where we are today
hey everyone today is tuesday it's two
o'clock in the afternoon
we had our quality improvement meeting
today in which we go over our numbers
for the trauma
center our volume our outcomes our
mortality that sort of thing
our overall trauma numbers were much
lower but our overall penetrating
numbers were much higher
usually our percentage of penetrating
trauma is somewhere around 20
but for the months of april may was
significantly higher and more like 25
it's you know hard to know if that's a
blip in the statistics or if that's a
real
phenomenon that more people were
shooting and stabbing each other
despite the overall drop in trauma
volumes
it's july 15th wednesday 7 30 p.m
the news today is that the federal
government
has decided that the hospitals and
local public health authorities should
now be reporting their covet data
to a centralized database run by the
white house
and not to the cdc this is concerning
because of
transparency issues and data sharing
issues
and accountability issues and privacy
i want to take care of patients and
operate on sick people
and do my job and do it well we are busy
here we are drowning
we are stressed out it is incredibly
frustrating
to be part of my french balls deep and
taking care of a lot of sick patients
and have the government types not be
able to
deal with this effectively i'm just like
guys figure this out
today is thursday july 16th and
there's been two situations in this last
week that have
been sort of like that's kind of
interesting one is a lady
who has a really terrible and difficult
and complex
abdominal wall hernia and normally
between
operations we would be removing the
breathing tube and putting it back in
for just for surgery but because she has
coveted
and uh reintubating and extubating is
just such a
massive exposure for the doctor who's
intubating the anesthesiologist who's
intubating the nurse and the respiratory
therapist who would be extubating
this lady who otherwise would be awake
and walkie-talkie just with this
abdominal problem
has been intubated this entire time and
then another patient
that's been sort of different because
she has covid is this um lady that we
admitted overnight she's a young lady
um who was a witness to
be assaulted by three different people
she was getting kicked and punched and
all these other things
she has this massive fever so is that
from
an intestinal perforation that we don't
know about or is that from her coven
all other things being equal she
probably would have earned herself an
abdominal
operation to go in and check on things
but right now we're just chalking that
fever up to
coven so we'll have to see she's sort of
a mystery at the moment so
we'll follow her closely and see sort of
how she plays out and we are being asked
to recycle our n95s
ppe seems adequate here but next to
every
covet or negative pressure room there is
a bin to recycle the n95s
it's friday july 17th 6 10 in the
morning i slept in a little bit
um i got a bunch of frantic text
messages from the on-call trauma team
last night
uh because there was not a single icu
bed in the entire house and they needed
me to move somebody
and uh we had to pick and choose these
are people who under normal
circumstances would probably
take another day or two of observation
in the intensive care unit but
you know with uh the crunch for beds we
had to sort of boot them out a day early
um so i think they'll be fine but
it was just it was a very surreal
conversation that i was having last
night
so i just realized that
on this day two weeks from now
i will be walking out of the doors of
this hospital for the last time
i will finish my year of
critical care fellowship and that will
complete 10 years of medical training
and i'll be done so two more days
running in the icu
then a few trauma calls in the last two
weeks and
i am out of here our center is also
participating in a couple of clinical
trials for covid which is pretty
exciting
one trial that we're involved in is
looking at mesenchymal stem cells which
are
just stem cells naturally found in the
body that have the potential to become
anti-inflammatory type cells dr baudish
is coming around and keeping tabs from
all the patients collecting various data
points and
seeing whether it's helping
good morning it's saturday july 18th
i'm heading into the hospital for my
last
day ever rounding the icu at county
fellowship has 12 days left in it so one
more day
rounding the unit and then uh four
24-hour trauma calls in 11 days
i don't that doesn't sound like that
much but that's a lot but
it's good it'll be good um it's a good
strong way to finish this year
okay well it's saturday july 18th i am
finished rounding um the overnight
trauma team was very busy we have a
many new patients many very sick new
patients and a lot of them have coveted
so just another day at the office
because our hospital is cohorting the
coveted patients and so strict about
that meaning
the coveted patients can only go to
certain units a lot of our trauma
patients are ending up in the medical
icu these medical icu nurses are now
being asked to take care of
trauma patients who have hemorrhaged you
know a ridiculous amount of blood volume
or have bad head injuries
it's not sort of in their wheelhouse the
way it's in the wheelhouse of
the nurses up on five you know it just
takes a little bit more communication it
takes a little bit more patience
it's for the greater good of the
hospital and the staff and the patients
that we sort of cohort all these
coveted positive folks together so we
just have to kind of do what we have to
do and adapt
in that sense it's july 20th it's 9
20 p.m a little bit past halfway done
with this 24 hour trauma shift i would
say these last 12 days have been
um sort of less of a whirlwind than the
first surge of covid back in march and
april
when la was so shut down all we could do
was focus on taking care of covet
patients and that's what we were doing
but now since la is open and we have
this second surge
we are just doing a little bit of both
at the same time
operating on a cova patient is like real
slow everything that usually takes a
long time takes 10 times longer
from anesthesia getting all set up with
their very special space helmets to
intubating safely
and clearing out the room for 30 minutes
with negative pressure it's been so
up and down in a roller coaster and
nothing surprises me anymore
like my life four weeks ago was really
different from my what life
four weeks before that was really
different from my life four weeks before
that so when there's new policies or new
developments or
new steps we have to take or new
interesting twists on
the way covet and trauma can mix up it's
made me more dynamic
it's made our nurses more dynamic and
our staff more dynamic you just have to
roll the punches
because the punches are nonstop it's
been crazy but we're used to it
we're used to crazy around here it's
what we do we specialize in crazy
oh my good lord so now i'm finishing my
24 hour shift last night was like one of
the craziest nights i've ever had here
one of these young kids 28 years old he
was very unstable very sick
meanwhile while that's going on i get
the trauma page that uh gunshot wounds
coming in so run downstairs see that
it's a lady
who got shot through the arm into the
right upper quadrant
um and it went sort of all the way
across her abdomen and caused a bunch of
trouble
and the pager goes off again it's a stab
wound to the chest
so there's a two centimeter little
laceration in the front of the heart
so i said okay so we put a little stitch
in that and
holy crap he comes back to life heart
starts beating there's a real blood
pressure i'm like
meanwhile my other team is working on
this gunshot wound who obviously also
has covid
uh of course my stab wound guy did not
luckily everybody was in there wearing
their space
suits and their special masks because we
sort like i said before we treat
everybody when they're coming in like
they do have coven and you know thank
god we do because
50 of our patients last night had coven
so yeah i'm pretty jazzed right now
pretty amped up thank god everyone this
morning is doing much better than they
were last night
so all in all a very positive but very
busy night
i have full faith in the staff that
remains here to keep doing what they do
which is
work really hard and care really deeply
and take care of each other and take
care of patients we
really should never forget a lot of
people in the world have lost
family members their moms and their dads
and their kids and their brothers and
their sisters
that sort of puts everything to a little
bit of perspective and
a little bit of inconvenience here there
or a little bit of
a need for ingenuity and adaptability i
think that's just a small price to pay
so i think that's it for me i'm signing
off
it's been great talking to you guys and
sort of keeping this time as a little
time capsule
all right peace out
you